[Musique]
pascal bruckner vous parler de ce
problème de la pologne vous avez invité
henri weber qui nous parlera tout à
l'heure du nicaragua mais il revient
d'un voyage en pologne et son enquête
j'allais dire journalistique est surtout
portait justement sur ce phénomène de
rationnement et qui était assez
dramatique en ce moment en pologne
vous venez de rentrer vous avez passé
j'allais dire votre temps à observer
justement ces polonais c'est polonaise
qui font la queue 24 heures sur 1,4
pratiquement d'après ce que l'on sait
devant les boutiques et les différents
magasins oui alors j'ai effectivement
passé une semaine dans les queues
principalement à varsovie mais également
dans quelques villes de province et on
n'a pas idée ici en france de ce que
représente ce phénomène en pologne
on sait simplement que les que son très
long et qu elle dure plusieurs heures et
que souvent pour des objets alimentaire
elle dure toute la nuit mais on ne
connaît pas un autre type 2 que qui est
probablement le plus éprouvant pour la
population c'est laid que pour obtenir
des biens de consommation durables ou
les biens d'équipement et qui elle ou
alors des papiers administratifs et qui
elle sait que dure plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois et implique toute une
organisation et mobilise la population
mobilise son énergie l'épuisent
littéralement par exemple j'ai fait la
queue à varsovie pour obtenir des
meubles avec un varsoviens qui voulaient
obtenir des meubles c'est une queue qui
duraient déjà depuis deux mois et il y
avait encore deux mille inscrits sur la
liste parce qu'évidemment c'est que là
ne peuvent pas se dérouler physiquement
elle s'organise mais injustement on
s'organise à l'intérieur de ces files
d'attentes
alors cette queue et hélas la plus
grande organisation en pologne la plus
grande organisation de masse n'est pas
comme on le croit ici solidarité le
syndicat mais l'organisation spontanée
des que c'est à dire que il y a quinze à
vingt millions de polonais qui sont
organisés en permanence dans des queues
et c'est que org secrète leurs propres
dirigeants leur comité social de que
leurs dirigeants naturel île secrète
leur propre droit par exemple il y à un
âge où l'attend
les files d'attentes île secrète leur
propre jurisprudence par exemple il y à
l'égalité de tous deux
la queue mais lorsque il y à une femme
enceinte elle n'a pas une priorité
absolue mais elle dispose d'une vitesse
de progression améliorée dans là que
j'avais lorsque là qu avance d'un cran l
avance de 2 ou 3 même chose pour les
invalides ou pour les retraités
accompagnées d'enfants en bas âge
bref il ya une économie politique de la
que régis d'ailleurs peu par le
libéralisme c'est à dire que les
polonais sont prises sont propriétaires
de leur place dans la file d'attenté la
file d'attenté comme vous dites ils
peuvent la vendre et le font par exemple
au consulat de france en ce moment il ya
une queue de plusieurs centaines de
mètres tous les matins et le prix d'une
place pour pouvoir déposer un dossier
pour un visa dans la journée et 2 500
zlotys c'est-à-dire un dixième du
salaire mensuel d'un polonais alors je
crois que là on a une idée assez précise
de ce qui se passe dans ce pays
effectivement et il n'y a pas mieux que
quelqu'un qui a vécu est carrément qui a
étudié ce problème pour le pour bien en
parler merci henri weber
[Musique]